hast du mal klicksum gesehen nein noch
nicht das ist gut ja dann kennst du
nicht unsere Eingangsfrage nein ich hab
mich gar nicht vorbereitet super alte
Sau hat nichts gemacht vor vorzubereit
wir haben eine Standardfrage am Anfang
weil sich daraus immer die gleichen
Fragen sind egal wer Daag und die erste
Frage die ist auf jeden Fall immer die
gleiche wie ist die
Lage persönlich oder in in der Welt das
kannst du beantworten wie du möchtest äh
persönlich m sehr angenehm sehr
ausgeglichen eine Woche Köln eine Woche
am Stück im gleichen Hotel eine Woche
nicht reisen müssen wundervoll die
Weltlage schwierig mhm wie kann man als
Rampensau ausgeglichen sein gar nicht
eigentlich es war eigentlich die
klassische Standardfragen
eingangslüge mit der ich immer einsteige
um so eine heile Welt vorzugaukeln nein
letztlich ist man natürlich permanent
unter Strom hektisch und und ähm und am
gucken und am arbeiten und äh das das
ist natürlich so also äh ich habe vorhin
schon wieder gemerkt als ich Frühstück
ich bin eigentlich nervös geworden als
ich da schon 12 Minuten vor meinem
croisson saß und dachte verdammt noch
mal du hast immer noch nichts gemacht
heute gut ich glaube jetzt nichts von
all dem ehrlich nein ja wirklich Minuten
muss ich aufstehen musst du hochgehen
Computer hochfahren Mails checken Mails
beantworten mich über die
Nachrichtenlage updaten hat das mit
deinem Beruf zu tun also auch so wie du
dein Beruf ausübst dass du da immer am
Puls der Zeit sein musst ja ja ja sonst
sonst geht es nicht also ich arbeite nun
wirklich AK
und das macht man entweder ganz oder gar
nicht das heißt entweder man ist
wirklich permanent auf auf Themensuche
und unterwegs und guckt was passiert was
geht oder man muss es bleiben lassen und
sagen na ja ich spiel es halt so runter
das Programm und ansonsten lass ich mir
tagsüber gut gehen und um 15 Uhr kommen
die Mädels aufs Zimmer
gut aber trotzdem bevor wir über die
Mädels reden sehr interessantes Thema
ist diese Fähigkeit über dich gekommen
also war die von vorne rein da oder hast
du irgendwas aufgespürt und dann
entwickelt das war eigentlich
eigentlich da solange ich denken kann
also bewusst wurde es mir erst als ich
mich damit retten musste in der Schule
weil ich einfach keine Möglichkeit hatte
war sehr unsportlich und sehr dick
damals und musste irgendwas tun und da
hi half mir nur der Humor weil ich
anders auch nicht an an an Mädels ran
was natürlich mit 14 das vorrangige Ziel
ist konntest du dich denn retten ja ja
ja darüber dann schon also dann dann
habe ich es eben über Humor getan da
wurde es mir zum ersten Mal sozusagen
bewusst dass es nach außen funktioniert
dass andere drüber lachen aber ganz früh
bei mir zu Hause bei meiner Mutter wurde
parodiert also wir haben uns auch
gegenseitig parodiert wenn es Krisen gab
W es wurden andere das war irgendwie das
war so von Anfang an irgendwie da auch
dieser dieser Drang nach außen zu gehen
irgendwie ist lustig zu sein
und und
alles was man wahrnimmt irgendwie
auch auch lustig zu machen das das war
von Anfang an da ja und das
mit der Zeit hat man das natürlich
professionalisiert und kanalisiert aber
es war immer da es gibt ja undankbare
und dankbare ich sag mal Opfer
wahrscheinlich wie weit geht dann die
beishhemmung nein die ist nicht die ist
nicht wirklich da weil das so läuft ja
auch das Geschäft nicht aber es ist ja
heute sozusagen state of the art dass
man sich als Prominenter auch wahnsinnig
drüber amüsiert dass man
parodiert wird dass ähäh man sich äh
dass es Prominente gibt andere
Prominente Kabarettisten die sich überin
lustig machen das gehört ja schon fast
zum Geschäft dass man das toll findet ne
das macht schon fast das
kabarettistische Geschäft wieder
schwerer weil es eben so ein so ein Usus
ist haha jetzt bin ich dran also die die
die letzten die sich darüber aufregen
sind dann sind dann
Leute wie Jürgen klensmann wo man dann
sagt das ist natürlich ganz peinlich wie
er dann nervös wird und sich über eine
wirklich witzige Karikatur in in der Tat
so aufregen kann ne aber ansonsten äh
hört man ja dann NS ne insofern gibt's
auch keine beishhemmung und man hat auch
keine Chance in die Presse zu kommen
durch irgendein Gag weil sich niemand
mehr nein das Skandal Level liegt
unendlich hoch ne das ist so und im
Grunde genommen kann man fast sagen das
ist eigentlich Niklas lumann
Selbstreferentialität des Mediums in die
ist das soziilosie Soziologie Soziologie
Philosophie und beides noch mal hoch
zwei okay die Meter Meter Meter eben
genau und das ist aber eigentlich ist
das Luma selbstreferenzialität des
Mediums es ist so Z sagen man befindet
sich im Grunde in diesem
Unterhaltungsbereich ganz schnell in
einem in einem in einer luftleeren
Parallelwelt ne man kann alles sagen man
kann alles machen es stört keinen
es interessiert die Betroffenen nicht
die da irgendwie äh
verarscht werden oder über die man sich
lustig macht oder über die man Poen
schreibt im besten fallle interessiert
es das Publikum und das ist natürlich
auch das eigentliche Ziel warum man es
macht aber das den den den Skandal oder
so zu erzeugen das war früher
sicher einfacher das geht heute
eigentlich nur noch mit mit
Missverständnissen ich habe in meiner
SWR Sendung in der letzten habe ich eine
Nummer gemacht wo ich einen
Fernsehreporter gespielt habe der immer
noch vor den Schulen des Landes steht
weil er wartet dass wieder
einer einer austickt wie in Winnenden ne
war eine böse medienti könnte schon eine
Grenze ja das war eine ganz böse
Mediensatire daraufin habe ich aber von
Zuschauer ganz viel böse Post bekommen
die sie böse beklagt haben aber das war
natürlich Leute die da emotional nah am
Thema waren und auch nicht erfasst haben
um was es geht ne es war mit keinem Wort
eine eine Opfer Verhöhnung oder eine
täterüberhöhung sondern es war eine ganz
klar hoch präzise ausgearbeitete
Mediensatire das kann man dann da ist
dann schon da merkt man hey guck mal da
ist doch sozusagen wie wellbeck gesagt
hat drücken Sie den Finger in die Wunde
und drücken sie schön fest zu
was er ja auch bei sich ausmacht holbeck
ist ja ein kurz zur Erklärung Autor
Belgier
Elementarteilchen wo es wirklich ans
Eingemachte geht ist keine Satire aber
aber schon sehr lustig auch ja bist du
so Künstler wie er weil er sagt ja man
muss anderen Leuten weh tun ihnen
schaden man muss das alles mal gemacht
haben
m um daraus schöpfen zu können
nein also soweit gehe ich nicht ich habe
für mich war dieses ich habe von ihm
gelesen es gibt ein einen frühen Aufsatz
von ihm Ende der 90er als er noch vor
allem Gedichte geschrieben hat der heißt
lebendig bleiben ein leitfahren liegt
bei mir auf Nachttisch ja bei mir auch
das ist natürlich ganz ganz groß also
das war das ist für mich wirklich
sozusagen mit der Zeit eine eine schon
sowas wie eine eine kabarettistische
Bibel geworden es ist maßlos übertrieben
was er schreibt äh und es ist natürlich
ähm nicht eins zu eins zu nehmen aber
sehr viel Wahres drin sehr sehr sehr
viel Wahres drin kann ich nur jedem
empfehlen der in irgendeiner Form wie
auch immer glaubt er müsse kreativ
arbeiten das ist eigentlich sozusagen
die Bibel wo man sagt dass wenn man das
mal gelesen hat dann ist ist geht es
eineem mit vielen besser aber ihm geht's
ja nicht gut dabei er sagt ja auch man
soll einem gar nicht gut gehen ja ja er
sagt ja es darf einem nicht gut gehen ja
das wie git denn
dann also dir geht's richtig beschissen
also wenn ich mir geht absolut
beschissen nein aber es geht sag wir mal
so es ist glaube ich eher sozusagen ich
habe für mich festgestellt es ist ähm
das ein ein lebendig bleiben durch
Ambivalenz ne also dass man
nie in dieser totalen Entschiedenheit
nicht in so eine Ruhe kommt in so ein
ach ich habe ja alles habe ja meinen
Platz dann gibt es sicher nichts mehr
was von außen als Impuls kommt wo hast
du diese ganze ich sag mal dieses
philosophische Fundament her hat dich
das interessiert studiert ja ich habe
sech Jahre Philosophie studiert oh gott
hilft das oder stört das nein sowohl als
auch nein nein ich finde es hilft also
äh nicht unmittelbar also nicht dass ich
jetzt irgendwie äh ich würde mich jetzt
nicht auf die Bühne stellen wollen und
und Philosophie erklären das nicht aber
es hilft
weil man sich doch mit etwas beschäftigt
hat was außerhalb des des eigenen
Horizonts liegt den man sonst so
permanent beackert ne und weil weil man
vielleicht wenn man es entsprechend
angeht lernt Strukturen zu verstehen
Analogien herzustellen auch eher gegen
den Strich denken lernt was ja für den
Kabarettisten ganz wichtig ist Themen
von der anderen Seite anzugehen sowas da
hat es mir extrem viel gebracht aber
jetzt nicht unmittelbar es eh so eine
Quelle es ist so ein immer wieder ich
lese bis heute sehr viel in der Richtung
und es ist immer wieder dann schön diese
diese Texte zu lesen und da abzutauchen
und zu sagen ich muss mich jetzt nicht
unbedingt nur mit Tagesgeschäft
beschäftigen ist das eine Art eine
Perspektive zu finden das auch ja auf
Dinge zu gucken ja absolut ja das stimmt
also das das ist so und die anders zu
sehen ganz genau das ist das Einzige was
mich am Kabarett interessiert also dass
man wirklich sozusagen verschiedene
Ebenen herstellt das Publikum verführt
irritiert an Gedanken aufbaut die
Richtung wechselt und am Ende das dann
wieder
zusammenfügt das ist das was mich reizt
wo man einfach danach rausgeht wie ich
aus ein paar Programmen auch im
rausgegangen bin und danach gedacht habe
WoW das beschäftigt mich das das das
wirkt nach das ist damit mache ich jetzt
nicht gehe nicht raus und mache damit
Schluss weil der Abend ist vorbei
sondern irgendwie geht mir das nach ne
und das ist immer die Wirkung die ich
erzeugen wollte dass man im besten Fall
auch da
ähm ambivalent oder aufgerührt rausgeht
und nicht so ah ja war lustig was war da
noch mal über was hat der geredet weiß
ich mehr also du willst eine Ambivalenz
der Widersprüchlichkeit die Menschen
sollen am Ende verunsichert eher sein
als ich würde eher sowas wie sagen wie
wie wie wie irgendwie berührt oder oder
ähm
ja dass irgendwie was bleibt ne das wie
nach einem guten Gespräch wo man sagt
man geht nicht es gibt Gespräche da geht
man am sitzt man an der Bar unterhält
sich geht danach ins Bett und denkt sich
ja es war nett man hätte aber auch eine
Stunde früher gehen können ne aber hat
nicht geschadet schläft man Morgen eine
Stunde länger und es gibt die Gespräche
wo man danach rausgeht und denkt
Wahnsinn es war so toll es hat mir so
viele anstößse gegeben worüber ich jetzt
nachdenken will es jede Minute hat sich
gelohnt es hätte noch eine Stunde länger
dauern können aber dann gibt ja noch das
gute Gespräch was nach Wirkung hat was
Konsequenzen hat und es gibt das Gute
Gespräch was zwar super ist aber es ist
nicht gemeint ja es ist einfach nur man
hat sich vielleicht intelligent
unterhalten man hat vielleicht einen
wichtigen Punkt ab angetoucht aber
keiner zieht daraus Konsequenzen weil er
zu bequem ist ziehst du denn
Konsequenzen aus dem was du verarbeitest
wie lebst du ist was ist dein Leben ist
dein Leben dieser Beruf oder gibt es bei
dir zwei Bereiche Privatleben und Beruf
oder ist das so ineinander verworben
verwoben dass du es nicht trennen kannst
ich kann es kaum trennen also es ist
natürlich gibt es privatbereiche aber es
ist es fließt letztlich alles da hinein
also alles was diesen Beruf ausmacht
fließt auch ins Private mit ein ist
nicht so dass ich jetzt permanent lustig
sein muss privat überhaupt nicht aber
es ist alles findet in diesem in diesem
Umfeld statt und
äh das ist auch nicht mehr man kommt ich
hab mir das lange vorgemacht ach so so
wie man das von den Clowns kann
privat ganz traurig und ernst und ganz
anders aber es ist Quatsch es stimmt
nicht man übt privat man man man testet
privat Poen aus man lässt auf der Bühne
irgendwann mit einer gewissen
Entwicklung eine Nachdenklichkeit zu die
eigentlich sonst privat wäre aber es ist
letztlich fließt es ineinander also
alles andere ist auch Quatsch natürlich
gibt's eine Bühnenfigur die ist noch ein
bisschen anders als die Privatperson
aber es vermischt sich es vermischt sich
letztlich alles und es muss glaube ich
auch so sein also ich habe das immer das
habe ich mal gelesen bei bei bei Markus
lüpperts dem Maler der mal gesagt hat
meine Arbeit stand immer im Zentrum das
wussten alle die mit mir gelebt haben ne
äh und das ist bei mir auch
so deswegen willst du keine dauerhafte
Partnerin das habe ich ja nie gesagt na
sagen wir mal so du hast dich ambivalent
gehäuert nein das habe ich nicht ich
habe nur
gesagt
ich habe nur gesagt dass ich nicht
heiraten werde oder will und so und
diese und das nicht will diese
Institution nicht nicht meine ist wie
ich auch im Programm sage aber nein
dauerhafte Partnerschaften das ist ja
nicht ausgeschlossen das ist ja nicht
das ist ja nicht so dass es ein Tabu ist
gar nicht aber könnst sie sowas
vorstellen Familie Kinder nein das geht
nämlich dann wahrscheinlich nicht es
ging schon viele Kollegen haben bewiesen
dass es geht das ist eine Frage des
Willens aber bei dir jetzt der Fall wenn
du sagst dass Beruf und Privatleben
soinander verknüpft sind ich sehe dafür
ich möchte das nicht ich sehe mich da
nicht in der Rolle ich möchte das für
ich sehe das nicht in meinem ich sehe
dafür im Moment keinen Platz in meinem
Leben vielleicht sehe ich das in 10
Jahren anders äh so offen muss man sein
ich habe schon für viele Dinge in meinem
Leben keinen Platz gesehen und plötzlich
war er da aber ich habe früher nie Sport
gemacht ich hatte einfach gesagt hab
geglaubt ich hätte keine Zeit heute
mache ich das regelmäßig heute könnte
ich gar nicht mehr ohne oder ich habe
lange in in als ich studiert habe auf 23
madrat gewohnt in einer Wohnung die die
die man nur als Student mieten konnte
damals in Freiburg und di Jahre habe ich
mich damit beschäftigt wenn ich fertig
bin mit Studium wie kann ich diese
Wohnung halten obwohl ich nicht mehr
studiere ne weil ich ich wollte nicht
größer wohnen ich fand das
rausgeschmissenes Geld ich wollte ich
wollte in diesem genau in diesem kleinen
Bereich auf 23 Quadratmeter mein Leben
verbringen und das irgendwann bin ich
dann deutlich größer geworden weil ich
es nicht mehr ausgehalten habe und
vorher habe ich es ausgeschlossen aber
dennoch ist beim Thema Thema Familie
Kinder ist bei mir so ich
ich sehe da in meinem Leben kein Raum
ich könnte das nicht ausfüllen also ich
könnte diese Rolle nicht füllen
und ich finde man wenn man sowas macht
dann muss man da auch Zeit für haben
sich widmen ich habe dann sehr sehr
großen Respekt vor Leuten die das machen
ich finde das eine unglaublich große
Aufgabe die ich sehr respektiere man man
muss aber man muss schon da muss ich
finde da gehört schon eine Entscheidung
dazu ein Wille eine Lust das das zu
machen und ich habe
nicht so großen Respekt vor so Leuten
die sagen na ja es passt nicht so aber
wir machen es halt mal weil ich finde
dazu ist die Verantwortung die man DAF
ein neues Leben übernimmt viel zu groß
und in meinem
Leben meine Energie findet auf anderen
Feldern statt du hast es vorhin selber
gesagt du guckst ich sag mal Auswegs
ausweglose Situationen an du guckst
dahin wo es weh tut wie hieß noch mal
das Fremdwort für die ausweglosen
Situationen aporin aporin m du
beschäftigst dich also mit Themen die
wirklich ja ein schweren Konflikt äh äh
im Mensch sein sage ich jetzt
mal bedeuten tut das nicht selber weh
oder ist der das Kabarett machen da das
Ventil das ist genau das Ventil das ist
das Ventil diese
ganze themenschwere und Schwere der
Überlegungen lustig zu machen weil am
Abend ist mein Anspruch auch der einer
Leichtigkeit bei aller ernsthäftigkeit
muss das
Ganze sehr sehr leicht daherkommen um
punktuell schwer zu werden aber ich
möchte nicht und ich kann auch nicht
zwei Stunden am Stück weltanklage machen
ich wärst du ansonsten ein schwermütiger
Nietzsche auf der Couch geworden das ist
natürlich ein großes Wort aber wer ein
ein schwermütiger
Mensch oder ein schwer oder ein Nietsche
werden soll oder will der wird das und
der wird nicht Kabarettist aber
vielleicht auch verdanken dem Umstand
dass du dick und hässlich warst
natürlich ja absolut ähm ja also das das
im Nachhinein bin ich für die ganzen
schwierigen Situationen auch dankbar
weil man man lernt daraus und ohne die W
wäre ich nicht das was ich heute bin
insofern das hütet mich auch davor
Menschen gegenüber böse zu sein ne von
von früher weil letztlich danke ich
Ihnen allen wasast du mein in in deren
Haut ja und letzt letztlich habe ich den
allen was zu verdanken die ich damals so
in der Schule die me me meine Mäppchen
und Schultaschen durch die Gegend
geworfen haben die ich da gehasst habe
und und die bin ich heute letztlich
dankbar ne dafür dass sie das gemacht
haben weil was wäre ohne das aus mir
geworden was wäre gewesen wenn ich mit
der Hypothek eines geglückten Lebens in
die
in ein bedingungslos geglückten Jugend
so es sie denn gibt ins Leben gestartet
wäre ne dann wäre ich vielleicht heute
bei der Bank und hätte schon Geld
verzockt und müsste mein Leben fürchten
dann beenden wir das Gespräch mit der
ungewöhnlichen Erkenntnis dass mobben
auch was Gutes hat ja so kann man sehen
vielen Dank gerne